plusieurs milliers d'entrepreneurs et de
responsables politiques sont attendus
aujourd'hui à saint pétersbourg pour le
forum économique organisé tous les ans
par la russie tous les ans ou presque
l'événement avait été annulée en 2020
qu'ovide oblige cette année malgré la
pandémie le forum ouvre ses portes mais
sous restriction sanitaires un rendez
vous incontournable consacrée aux grands
enjeux économiques de la planète les
détails avec hélène masse collier c'est
l'autre grand rendez-vous de l'économie
internationale
surnommé le davos russe le forum
économique de saint-pétersbourg rouvre
ses portes dans la venise de la baltique
trois jours à vivre au rythme des
conférences bien sûr mais aussi des
signatures de contrats
pour cette 24e édition près de 150
événements sont prévus
1200 entreprises des invités venus de
130 pays
dirigeants des plus grandes sociétés
russes et étrangères chef d'état est
économiste et changeront en présentiel
ou kovy 19 oblige en visioconférence le
forum axé sur les questions de
l'économie russe et internationale se
donne une mission particulière cette
année
redonner un élan aux relations
économiques mondiales lourdement
affectés par la pandémie et la fermeture
des territoires au fil des ans le forum
a toujours été un lieu pour discuter des
problèmes les plus urgents auxquels la
fédération de russie et les économies
mondiales sont confrontés l'événement de
cette année ne sera pas différent la
nécessité d'un dialogue ouvert et
constructif est particulièrement
évidente à l'heure actuelle la pandémie
du coït 19 a touché tous les pays du
monde et a gravement réduit les liens
internationaux
il est essentiel de travailler ensemble
alors que nous forgeons la voie du
rétablissement
au menu des discussions également l'arc
tic les objectifs de développement de la
russie jusqu'à 2030 la santé ou encore
la digitalisation des entreprises et
parmi les participants cette année
le président de total
et représentant du bénin ou du gabon et
un invité d'honneur l'émir du qatar
reflet du renforcement des relations
qatar aux russes ces dernières années le
cheikh tamim bin hamad al thani sera
accompagné de près de 50 organisations
venues de l'émirat une telle
représentation à grande échelle de
l'état du qatar au forum économique de
saint-pétersbourg 2021 est la meilleure
preuve des vastes perspectives de
coopération entre le qatar et la russie
ainsi que de la volonté des parties
d'approfondir et d'élargir les relations
nous sommes convaincus que notre
collaboration à travers cet important
forum sera productive
nous sommes impatients de forger de
nouveaux partenariats et d'élargir les
liens commerciaux et économiques pour
l'europe
seul le chancelier autrichien sebastian
kurz apparaîtra en ligne dans les
discussions côté français pas de
représentants politiques même si
l'hexagone reste le premier investisseur
en russie malgré un contexte de tension
diplomatique entre moscou et l'union
européenne
le thème choisi cette année de nouveaux
ensembles l'économie d'une nouvelle
réalité investissement emploi écologie
un contexte post crise sanitaire dans
lequel il convient en effet de relancer
la machine économique